يورا لم يكن عام
2023 عاما سهلا في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اذ تواصلت الضغوط على جبهات
القتال ف فقت الاسلحه الغربيه والنوعيه
على
اوكرانيا وانتقلت الحرب الى العمق الروسي
مع توسع استهداف منشات حيويه في موسكو
ومدن عده اخرى تزامن ذلك وتطورات روسيه
صادمه حبس العالم على اثرها انفاسه وهو
يراقب تمردا عسكريا غير مسبوق كاد يفضي
الى اضطرابات
واسعه
في مطلع عام
2023 دخل الصراع مرحله جديده ولا سما مع
قرار حلف شمال الاطلسي فتح المجال للاعضاء
لتقديم انواع جديده من الاسلحه الى كيف
وذلك بهدف تعويض النقص لديها في سلاح
الاليات الثقيله وتحقيق التوازن خلال
المواجهات مع القوات الروسيه فسارعت
المانيا الى ارسال دبابات لي
وتبعتها الولايات المتحده بارسال دبابات
ابرامز وانظمه صواريخ متطوره وصلت حزمه
المساعدات الغربيه الى مستوى لم يسبق
تقديمه الى اي بلد منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه الامر الذي ساهم في توسيع مجالات
النطاق الجغرافي للعمليات واستهداف مواقع
عسكريه روسيه في الجبهه المقابله وسعت
روسيا نشاطها في استهداف المعدات الغربيه
وزادت الضغط على المدن الكبرى مستهدفه
محطات الكهرباء وامدادات المياه ومنشات
البنى التحتيه ووسعت دائره ضرباتها مع
انهيار صفقه الغذاء لتشمل الموانئ ومراكز
تخزين الحبوب والاسمده لكن مع كل ما سبق
يذهب خبراء عسكريون الى ان السمه البارزه
للعام الثاني من الحرب هي وجود صعوبات
بالغه في احراز اي من طرفي الصراع تقدما
ميدانيا كبيرا واخذت الجبهات ت تدريجيا
طابع الثبات وتحولت الى حرب استنزاف وفي
اب اغسطس حثت اوكرانيا مواطنيها في سن
التجنيد على تحديث بياناتهم في حمله تجنيد
وتعبئه عامه لمواجهه القوات الروسيه فاصبح
جنود الاحتياط الذين تتراوح اعمارهم بين
18 و60 عاما في مرمى الاستدعاء ومع اخفاق
الهجوم المضاد الذي شنته كيف في تحقيق
مكاسب الحرب ونضوب الاموال المطلوبه
لمواصله الحرب زار الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلنسكي في شهر كانون الاول ديسمبر واشنطن
بحثا عن سبل لتمويل الحرب في اطار مساع
اخيره لاقناع الكونجرس بتوفير المزيد من
التمويل
لبلاده كان التمرد العسكري لمجموعه فاغنر
في حزيران يونيو حدثا غير متوقع لموسكو
بعد ان وجه ياف جاني بريغوجين مؤسس
المجموعه انتقادات لاذعه لوزير الدفاع
الروسي شويو ورئيس هيئه الاركان فاليري
زيمو ورغم ان التمرد انتهى سريعا عبر
تسويه قادتها بيلاروسيا لم يمر سوى شهرين
حتى ضج العالم بخبر تحطم طائره كان يركبها
بريغوجين في طريقها من موسكو الى سينت
بيترسبورج ما ادى الى مصرعه من الاحداث
البارزه ايضا في مسار الحرب حمله الوساطه
التي اطلقتها قطر بين روسيا واوكرانيا من
اجل لم شمل اطفال قاصرين باهلهم انطلقت
مفاوضات عبر الوسيط القطري استمرت عده
اشهر وفي منتصف اكتوبر تشرين الاول نجحت
في اعاده اربعه قاصرين اوكرانيين الى
اسرتهم وتواصل بعدها اعاده بعض الاطفال
على دفعات يرى خبراء عسكريون ان المواجهات
الضاريه التي شهدتها عده جبهات من دون
احراز تقدم على الارض لاي من الطرفين يظهر
تراجع قدرات موسكو وكيف على تحسين الشروط
الميدانيه لتوفير اوراق ضغط على المستوى
السياسي ورغم ذلك بدات موسكو متمسكه
بمواقفها اذ جدد الرئيس بوتين تصميمه على
استمرار الحرب حتى تحقيق اهدافها في حين
بدا الموقف الامريكي متمسكا بالحاق
الهزيمه بروسيا وفي المقابل ظهرت خلافات
بين الحلفاء الاوروبيين ورفعت اطراف
اوروبيه صوتها مطالبه بفتح حوار مع
[موسيقى]
musco